[Applause]
fighting to the finish line is in paula
radcliffe DNA but now what she is
battling to protect the future of
women's sport she says it is under
threat from political correctness and
transgender athletes they think somehow
they're afforded another right everybody
else doesn't have and and that's what I
don't see you have to look at what
you're doing in relation to the fairness
of how that impact everybody else around
you you can't just say well I feel like
this so I'm going to go into that sport
and never mind everybody else that's
already in that sport and is in that
category I'm just gonna do what's the
best thing for me I don't think I think
that's a kind of selfish way to to look
at it all the former athletes have also
spoken out Martina Navratilova Kelly
Holmes and Sharon Davies have added
their views and since received abusive
messages online it's very dangerous
because there are vulnerable athletes
out there who can't make that
distinction between what's reality and
what's not and what somebody really
truthfully stands by and what somebody's
just been a troll Radcliffe is speaking
out now because she's worried about the
possible fall outs for the legal hearing
involving Olympic champion caster
Semenya samanya is not transgender but
some believe she's so dominant because
of a condition she has called
differences in sexual development that
means she has naturally higher levels of
testosterone athletics governing body
the iwf wants her to take hormone
suppressing medication but samanya has
appealed the decision with the verdict
expected next week it could also affect
some Enya's closest rival Francine Lian
Sabah the brandy runner one silver
behind her at the Rio Olympics but
revealed this week that she also has the
same condition it's a number of athletes
and could be a growing number who who
have those elevated levels of
testosterone and it's not just about
that either it's the fact that
essentially you have a body that has
almost gone through male puberty and
these stronger physiological differences
bone mass the strength not having to
deal with periods not having to worry
about
or managing your menstrual cycle around
competitions Radcliffe believes all the
sporting Federation's will be watching
the out
of the Simoni case closely those
ramifications for what it means in their
sports and for what it means for the
future of female sport and also what it
will do in terms of the whole
transgender question and will it open
the door up there to transgender
actually being able to say you know what
we don't need to bring our levels down
either we don't need to have any kind of
surgery we can just identify how we feel
and then we can just come in and compete
in women's sport and that would be the
death of women's sport Martha Kellner
Sky News